welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Jason jaffetz in for Sean
with non-stop scandals and growing
concerns over his cognitive capabilities
and his age our Democrats starting to
turn on Biden even the Atlantic which
endorsed him in 2020 is now calling for
Biden to step aside While others are
expressing concern over his return to
the basement campaign strategy but this
has not stopped Joe from poking fun at
his age despite serious worries from
voters have a look
by the way I've been doing this a long
time
I know I don't look that old I know
I'm a little under 103. a lot of you are
tired
they're tired now I I get it
try being 110 and doing it again
I know I'm 198 years old
[Applause]
I call it being seasoned all the years I
was a senator
which were 270.
meanwhile the White House cocaine
Scandal isn't going away House
Republicans announced they are launching
an investigation which of course was
immediately dismissed by the left as a
political stunt and when asked about the
incident earlier today White House Press
Secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre completely
dodged the question have a look once and
for all whether or not the cocaine
belonged to the Biden family so perfect
a couple of things there we've answered
this question litigated this question
for the last two days exhaustively
um you know there has been some
irresponsible reporting about the family
and uh and so I gotta call that out here
and I have been very clear I was clear
two days ago when talking about this
over and over again as I was being asked
a question as you know in media Outlets
reported this the buying family was not
here they were not here
they were at Camp David they were not
here Friday they were not here Saturday
they were not here Sunday they were not
even here Monday they came back on
Tuesday so to ask that question is
actually incredibly irresponsible
and and um
I'll just leave it there
well Joe's problems Mount the question
is is Kamala Harris really any better
are giggling vice president launched
into yet another bizarre word salad this
time on the topic of culture have a look
culture is it is a reflection of our
moment and our time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and
and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because ever
it you know
it comes in the morning
we have to find ways to also Express
the way we feel about the moment in
terms of just having language and and a
connection to how people are
experiencing life hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else